[Music]
Weegee this is a new horror film about a
board game that's right and it's
produced by Michael Bay that means it's
gonna be great so someone's best friend
dies and everyone thinks that she
committed suicide however there's more
to the story than people are realizing
and most of it seems to be revolving
around this Ouija board that that girl
had found her friends find this thing
they decide to use it to try to get in
contact with their deceased friend and
then everything goes wrong
as I said Michael Bay produced this
movie now let's look at the track record
that he has had in the past in regards
to producing horror films he produced
the remake of the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre the remake of am knieval horror
Texas Chainsaw Massacre at the beginning
the remake of The Hitcher the unborn the
remake of Friday the 13th and the remake
of Nightmare on Elm Street after reading
those titles off to you would it really
shock you that much if I told you this
movie sucked
it sucked it's a movie about a board
game okay watching this movie I tried to
get in the mindset of the writer what
were they thinking and I mean that in a
serious way well the movies called Ouija
so obviously we have to have some Ouija
board playing in the movie right yeah we
do okay so how many times do you think
we can tangibly make these characters
play the Ouija board before everyone
calls BS on them because so much weird
crap is happening well probably like
three or four times okay
so we'll have like three or four we G
board sessions in this movie right right
so what's gonna happen when they're not
playing the Ouija board they'll talk
about the Ouija board they'll think
about it and we'll have shots of it
they'll go to school and their jobs and
and they'll they'll just kind of crap
what are we gonna do when they're not
playing the Ouija board that's what this
movie feels like in fact I learned that
a large portion of this movie was reshot
which makes a lot of sense because once
certain things come to light in this
movie about what's actually going on
below the surface about what the
thing actually once none of the movie
makes sense anymore see there are great
twists in movies where you begin to look
back on the movie rethink the entire
thing and that's an awesome and very
smart thing that a writer can do when he
turns the tables on you and the rest of
the movie still makes sense the twist in
this movie cheats more than a dumb bully
in grade school who's flunking math the
entire film doesn't make sense anymore
once you actually learn what's happening
and since I do my best to keep my
reviews spoiler free I will warn you
that after I give my grade for this
movie I'm going to quickly discuss said
twist and why it sucks all that being
said though this isn't an offensively
bad horror film you can sit and probably
watch this movie you'll be bored it
won't be very entertaining but it's not
gonna make you hate yourself it's
actually a nice looking movie it's well
shocked it's a sleek-looking picture for
the most part the screenplay is so
stupid though there are so many
laughable lines between these characters
that by the way are just the most
disposable horror characters on the face
of the earth the best part of this movie
is like it's opening ten minutes by far
I mean the rest of the movie after that
is just a downhill ride into oblivion
it's a stupid movie that's barely scary
it's a bunch of loud noises the only
time I even jump in this movie was when
somebody was there and it was their
friend
the light turned on and as loud boom
noise oh boy I jumped that's scary it's
not scary stop with that it's not fun
it's not enjoyable and it's not
frightening in the least it's just a
sound effect I'm gonna give ouija a
d-plus because it is a nice looking
movie the opening 10 minutes were
effective and it's not an offensively
bad movie but you do not need to see
this movie at all so as I said spoiler
warning for the big twist in this movie
for the entire movie you are thinking
that they are in contact with a young
girl who is trying to warn them about
her evil mother and their friends are
being killed supposedly by this mother
like they're dying okay and our main
character is told that she has to find
the body of this little girl and remove
the stitches from her mouth
so that she can be free so the little
girl can finally combat against her
mother the evil spirit that's bothering
them once she cuts the stitches and
frees this little girl's body or
whatever you figure out it's actually
the little girl that the mother was
trying to warn them about the little
girl
and then all hell breaks loose and
people are dying left and right but my
question is who was killing their
friends before this if the mothers not
the bad one and the girl who needed to
be freed because she was trapped is
actually the bad one how were people
dying before it doesn't make any sense
if she's trapped how is she able to kill
these people the entire movie doesn't
make sense anymore
I'm sorry screenwriters do you have any
respect for us as an audience anymore I
do not regret the decision I made before
I saw Ouija I purchased a ticket for
John wick and walked into eg instead
because I knew I had to see you eg and I
wanted to support John wick not this
crap guys seriously go see John wick I
saw it it's amazing I saw it twice
already I loved it
definitely check that movie out that
movie deserves your support not this but
there is some good news to all of this
my sponsorship with shutterstock.com has
continued there are a very cool website
that has stock images and stock photos
very high-quality stuff that you can
legally use in your short films a lot of
people have asked me about critiquing
short films I know personally that a lot
of independent filmmakers have a hard
time getting things like shots of LA or
shots of New York things that they need
in their movie to sell the location and
because of their sponsoring my videos
you can go to shutterstock.com right now
and enter the promo code Kris and get a
discount on your subscription how
awesome is that these guys are great
this is a really cool service for
independent filmmakers like myself like
you guys if you're into that because I
do know a lot of my viewers are trying
to make independent films and they have
a lot of really great stuff you can
check out on shutterstock.com and enter
that promo code Kris for a discount on
your subscription guys as always thank
you so much for watching if you did see
the movie I really wish you hadn't but
let me know what you thought below
thanks for watching guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck be nice
[Music]